[Applause]
to present the Oscar for Original Score
please welcome Sandra Bullock and Hugh
Brent
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's really only one way to follow
that selection of some of the greatest
movie scores ever written and that is to
introduce the one that will be joining
their company in a very short time the
nominees for the best original score'
are
[Music]
AI artificial intelligence by John
Williams a beautiful mind by James
Horner
[Applause]
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone by
John Williams
[Applause]
[Music]
Lord of the Rings the Fellowship of the
Ring by Howard Shore
[Applause]
[Music]
monsters incorporated by Randy Newman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Howard Shore from
Lord of the Rings a fellowship
[Music]
this is the first hospital for Howard
Shore for the film score the
London Philharmonic Orchestra and the
choral group the voices of London
[Music]
Krita
thank you to the members of the Academy
I had the good fortune of having such
fantastic collaborators on this project
Peter Jackson Fran Walsh Philippa boyens
who guided me an amazing journey through
middle-earth and it was just a
tremendously rewarding experience to
translate the words of Tolkien into into
music and I just feel blessed to be a
part of this production I want to thank
my wife Elizabeth and daughter may whose
love and support are incredible to me
and have just guided me on my journey
thanks to Bob Shaye Michael Lynn mark
our debt ski Paul bruised sag Barry
Osbourne everybody at the crew and in
tuxedo I love you ha thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]